okay so at this point the batmobile is
one of the most famous and iconic cars
in hollywood history first debuting in
detective comics is a red roadster the
car is transformed over the decades to
become as stylized as the batman behind
the wheel driving it but every new
iteration of the dark knight that we get
we also get a new car to fit and these
machines very much echo the personality
and attributes of whoever's in the cowl
just in the same way that james bond
will forever be tied to his range of
aston martins batman is very much tied
to the car and each one of them is
symbolic on a number of levels anton
first batmobile perfectly fit michael
keaton's stylized gothic take nolan's
tumblr echoed the groundedness and
practicality of bale's batman and robert
pattinson's is also a machine that
mirrors the way that he is
getting the tone of the movie right very
much depends on the choices that are
applied to the car and it can very much
make or break every incarnation of the
cape crusader the batman brilliantly
brings his right to life and throughout
this video we're gonna be discussing why
we think it's one of the best car chase
scenes ever put to film if you enjoyed
the video then we massively appreciate
the thumbs up and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day by the way welcome to the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul now
let's get into why we think chicks dig
the car
okay so if you followed us during our
run up to the release of the batman then
you'll know that we made several videos
on the new batmobile in 2020 it was
stated that the new ride would be
somewhat of a muscle car that bruce
built up in the same diy manner that he
crafted his armor through the film we
even get several hints towards this and
when he first enters the bat cave you
can't catch it under a top there's then
shots of chains the engine and
throughout the film reeves slowly
planted in our minds that it's coming
however what we didn't expect to see was
just how terrifying it was and in many
ways it perfectly mirrors batman at the
beginning of the movie when we're
introduced to the dark knight we hear a
monologue in which he talks about how he
looks in the shadows waiting for his
prey upon emerging at the train station
he strikes a terrifying figure and this
idea of batman coming out of this
darkness is too echoed in the
introduction of the car after a shootout
with penguin we watch his cobblepod
hears the menacing scream of the car's
engine from down a dark alleyway
similar to how batman appeared at the
train station this silhouette emerges
from the darkness growling like a
monster taking on a life of its own now
if you've seen our breakdown of the
opening scene then you'll know we very
much discussed how reeves took a lot of
inspiration from horror movies just in
the same way that killers like michael
myers and jason slowly walk towards
their prey the batman does too it really
laces the scenes with beer and the slow
lumbering footsteps from the darkness
are put in place to fill batman's
enemies with dread in the penguin's
point of view as he's lying upside down
as you have this kind of mythic
appearance of batman sort of with fire
raging behind him the horror inspiration
extends to the car as well and reeves
has stated in interviews that he very
much took inspiration from the john
carpenter classic christine growing up
this was one of my favorite films ever
because there was just something so
mysterious about the killer car
in case you haven't seen it it's based
on the book of the same name by stephen
king in which we watch a darkened them
on a car that has an evil presence
inside of it over time it twists its
timidona arnie into a complete
psychopath and we watch as his best
friend attempts to stop both him and the
car christine now what makes the movie
so memorable is that the ride is
indestructible and no matter what
happens to it it fixes itself it
mercilessly stalks its prey and there
are several scenes such as it driving
down the road on fire that reeves
clearly cripped from in order to make
his movie
now after scaring the crap out of the
penguin batman gives him a second chance
to escape which is something that
christine also did to its prey this kick
starts the chase scene that spans the
highways of gotham and on a technical
level reeves achieves the impossible
whenever you watch car chases and movies
you might notice that most of them are
filmed in daylight with pretty clear
weather conditions this extends to
things like bullet the matrix reloaded
the bourne identity and a lot more those
done at night tend to have either an
overpass or cover as the elements can
cause a lot of issues driving in the
rain is tough enough as it is but reeves
actually ignored the typical way of
doing things and he decided to do it in
wet conditions to add to the frantic
feeling of the film when discussing what
he was going for matt said to the real
blind podcast and greg
deliberately sought out the most
technically flawed anamorphic lenses you
could possibly have because i was really
obsessed with um the kind of 70s
filmmaking that was kind of like in the
vein of this this the tone that i
thought sort of was
our movie that was kind of like you know
the french connection or like uh clute
like these neo noir films and they were
you know that were shot you know many
cases anamorphic and those lenses of
that at that time were they were rough
this definitely comes across in the
movie and you very much feel like you're
in there with batman as he chases down
the penguin cars smash around them
there's several close calls and other
vehicles whizz past your head as you
follow the face off sound design often
adds to movies and anyone who's seen
this in imax knows how heart-pounding it
is as you hear the noises of the freeway
flying around you
it not only levitates how intimidating
that batman is but it also plants the
idea in oswald's head that he's
completely unstoppable he unloads uzis
on him steers cars into his path and
generally just throws everything at him
but it just isn't enough in our last
video we discussed how he was very much
like the terminator and that batman
would stop at nothing to close in on his
target reeves actually takes a lot of
similar iconography to what appeared in
terminator 1 and 2 and the unstoppable
machine shares some similarities with
the batman no matter what oswal puts in
his path he just keeps going constantly
in his rearview mirror right behind him
everything culminates with oswald
causing a crash that sends several
trucks into each other and these explode
destroying most of the highway as the
penguins celebrate we see that shot
which calls back to christine and the
batmobile rises through the fire almost
like a demon from the plains
[Music]
he hits the back of penguin's car and
sends him flying through the air which
we watch play out from the backseat of
his ride as the fire burns the night sky
the batman steps out and the black
figure stands strong against the orange
background this is upside down like a
bat and the contrast between the dark
shadows and the orange makes everything
pop very much bringing up the imagery of
a demon he slowly walks towards the
crashed car and this of course echoes
how he paced towards his victims earlier
in the movie the batman seems
unstoppable because of this and it very
much shows how he's elevating the idea
of fear in the criminals of gotham at
this start of the movie he was fighting
low-level thugs and when this moved up
to the iceberg lounge nobody there was
intimidated oswald even called him
sweetheart and this very much extended
to his bouncers and showed batman's
effect was very much low level however
this chase has risen his intimidation
and it's shown that he's now going after
those higher up the chain this of course
extends to the movie in which he ends up
taking down falcone before moving on to
the riddler the car chase very much sits
at the midpoint of the film and it shows
his progression through the ranks just
in the same way that the batman is a
tool of fear the car is too and elevates
the persona and legend that he's
crafting in gotham no matter what if he
has you in your sights the batman will
come for you and there's absolutely no
escape it's an incredible piece of
filmmaking that supplants the new
batmobile as one of the best ever and
it's the perfect way to introduce the
car not only does it strike fear into
its foes it also dominates the road
provides a relentless chase and gives us
an incredible scene and shows how
skilled reeves is as a filmmaker
[Music]
this is one of the standout scenes in
the movie and i hope you enjoyed our
breakdown of it obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts so make sure you
comment below and let me know i just
want to give a huge thank you for
getting our last perfect scene video to
half a million views and i hope you're
enjoying this series that we're now
doing regularly i've also just featured
on unleash the ghouls talking about why
batman and robin is so hilarious really
fun video a lot more a lot more jokes
than this one and definitely go check it
out right after this if not i don't know
what's wrong with you but i hope you
enjoy the rest of your week you take
care of yourself i'm out peace